so you want some good news well it
starts out bad yesterday we mentioned
the cold-blooded murders of two seniors
named Paul and Lydia every day they
visited their son's grave at Delaware's
Veterans Memorial Cemetery then last
month there they were shot dead by a
lone gunman amid the pandemic the story
went largely ignored Paul was an army
vet Lydia was a loving mom they had
three sons six grandkids and two
great-grandchildren
I bet you didn't hear about them until
you watched the five I found out that a
stranger Chris Miller a member of the
honor guard who performed at the
cemetery set up a GoFundMe page to help
the family pay the funeral costs so I
figured why not help last night the
donations climbed from mere thousands to
over 90 grand
now I'm not blowing my horn I'm blowing
your horn those who watched the show
last night and chose to help you're the
best so what's the lesson that people
want to help if you let them if your car
breaks down in Texas there's gonna be
four pickup trucks pulling over to help
if you slip on a sidewalk two
pedestrians will help you up when
there's a disaster people pitch in this
is vital to note as we're caught in a
whirlwind of demonic smears when anchors
of networks say all of America is
irredeemably racist when we have
politicians who prefer vengeance over
conversation but we have angry activists
who say it's legit to destroy somebody's
business when we have mobs who beat
people down rather than help them up
we need to remind those people what
decent people actually do we assist we
sacrifice so who else needs help officer
che my Colonus aged 29 was shot in the
head during a recent Vegas protest
Shay's paralyzed from the neck down
unable to speak what can we do for him
or his family that's the thing about
helping out it's easy it's addictive and
it feels great because it is so Dana
officer Michael onus they had a GoFundMe
page expecting five grand and now it's
up to 155 thousand but he's going to
require lifelong care so I don't know if
we're even I think this should be a
trend but we should people
go seek out officer Michael onus his
GoFundMe page and do what they did for
the Marino's last night do it for him
because he needs it as well one of the
things that is so remarkable and you and
I talked about this a bit last night
after the show is that it is an honor to
be on this show it's a real privilege to
be on this show we've been doing it
we're in our tenth year now and over and
over again
I am always just blown away by the
generosity and love that our viewers
show to one another and we really really
appreciate it yeah you know one it's
true even though some of our viewers get
mad at you you got to admit if if your
car broke down they pull over and help
you I think they'd do the same for you
Greg even though they get mad with you I
think that what we've got here is is
AMERICA AMERICA standing up and I just
love it you know to see Americans reach
out and you know give some comfort to a
grieving family in either situation and
to take to you know Americans rise up
out of a bad situation and make the good
come of it and I just think that's
wonderful it's great for the five family
you know I think it's got to extend to
all the damage that we see done to
people I don't care who does it but when
you have empathy and love in your heart
or you make a difference you do make a
difference America they give this
GoFundMe thing is great it is great I
know they they they make they make some
money off of this but it makes it so
much easier to help people it does and
and reach out to people instantly I just
want to thank all of the five viewers
who supported me through my mother's
cancer fight on social media and even
after her death because social media you
know it's a pit of bile and venom with
people literally there's a woman named
Marion cybersyn who tweeted me several
times a week if not daily threw out my
mom's lung cancer battle and after her
death she still does it all she tweets
me as X's and O's but you know what it
shows kindness and a generosity of
spirit and who we really are not just
Marian but who
as a nation Jesse I think that it's
great that this is that we we realize
humans are naturally inclined to help
other humans even you Jesse well it's
funny that you say that because
yesterday I wasn't going to donate but
then when I saw we were doing this
segment today I had to donate because I
wanted to tell everybody on television
that I donated that makes me feel really
good and then Greg you I just have to
say you did do a really good thing and
and it's really stands out because you
rarely do such good things and I just
want to compliment you because I do
think you're entering a new phase in
your life just like the country's going
through phases Greg's going through
phases this is kind of maybe your
baroque period you've got a tan my wife
said you look very thin you got the
black t-shirt like you're a very
successful actor you've now bought a
tactical shotgun I think you might be
going to church are you in a church
we're gonna have to wait and see